jeff
craig congratulations you both made it
through to the forged and fire final
and you're both one step closer to a
check for ten thousand dollars
in the first two rounds of competition
you forge a weapon in your signature
style
now we're sending you back to your home
forges where you will forge an iconic
weapon from history the warhammer
nice the warhammer is a medieval weapon
developed in the 14th century
they came about primarily as a response
to advanced armor technology
by this time the armorers had created
suits of plate armor
that was so hard and smooth that swords
would bounce off them
the warhammer could deliver its full
force to the target and do serious
damage
without having to penetrate the armor
its steel head with a spike on one side
had a handle that varied in length but
was generally just
long enough to be wielded with one hand
the spiked end could be used for hooking
the target's legs
reins or shield or used as an
armor-piercing device
as the use of body armor declined so did
the need for the warhammer
however it can still be seen today in
the popular film trilogy
the hobbit and has lent its name to the
board game
warhammer good luck bladesmiths
we'll see you in five days
i'm happy to be here at the home forge
i'm in my element i know what
all my tools are i know how to use my
tools so being here at home is a big
advantage for me
it takes a lot of steel to make the
mount of damascus that i'm gonna make
the plan for the day is we can get my
damascus made i'm gonna take the two
dissimilar metals
i'm gonna heat them up in my forge get
everything hot i'm gonna flux them
keep the oxygen out of there so the
scales doesn't form then i'm going to
beat them together
[Music]
i'm feeling a little nervous right now
making this damascus
i can get a bad weld i get a bad weld in
it though everything i've done so far
is ruined it's not a serviceable weapon
at that point
i'd have to scrap it and start again
i'm halfway through day two and i'm
getting the horns on the ram's head now
i'm bending the horns down so i have
like a very
organic curve to it
i run out of oxygen on my oxy acetylene
torch
i'm not exactly where i want to be on
the horns
the hammer head is starting to
wear on me i'm just going to have to
come in the morning
focus and hustle and make sure i'm doing
things right
don't make any mistakes i don't have any
room for that
right now rock and roll yesterday was a
busy day for
me i got the damascus forge for my head
and i've got it squared to about the
right
dimensions hammerhead's gonna start
taking shape for me today
the langlets are pretty much gonna lock
everything in
that is cool
i'm looking at these sharp corners in
these slots and i know that i'm going to
have a problem with this if i try to
full quench it
or i've put the langlet pockets in there
that can crack it's thinner than
everything else
i could literally end up with two pieces
of hammer
i'm gonna do a differential heat treat
on it i'm gonna try to harden the front
and harden the back but leave the middle
soft
if i crack the hammer while i'm
quenching it that could be disastrous
for me
yesterday i was able to get the
hammerhead
finish with all the detail getting
quenched
and today i'm getting into the handle
my plan is to add some upholstery rivets
down
the sides and the front and back of the
handle
it's going to be a mix of unique
decorative work
and traditional style warhammer with the
spike and the hammerhead
pretty happy with that gentlemen
the warhammer was primarily a close
quarters weapon but it was devastating
to anything it went up against which
occasionally was a castle door
so i'm going to take several strikes
against this oak door to see how well
the pick on your weapon penetrates
craig you ready i'm ready
well craig this really felt great in my
hands
it's got a nice balance to it your pick
i don't see any real distortion on it
the shape of your pick with that nice
drop hook to the end of it
really penetrated well and you could see
when i got it in that door how hard it
was to remove
yeah nicely done appreciate it
beautifully executed
thank you so jeff your turn you ready
we'll smash it all right
so we started losing pieces i could tell
that they're on there only decoratively
so i was able to continue on
good thing head's still right and tight
all right
the way your pick leans out towards the
front
gave a lot of penetration i was really
able to just blow parts out of this door
nicely designed well executed thanks
bait schmitz now it's time for the kill
test warhammers have been known
to deliver piercing blows into armor and
crush the person behind it i will
deliver strikes at this ballistic dummy
that's wearing armor
then we can see how much lethal damage
your warhammer can give
craig you're up are you ready i'm ready
let's do it
[Music]
craig love the balance of this blade
no indentations now let's see how much
damage we put on the dummy
no visible broken bones but it
definitely did pierce the skin
nice this will definitely
kill nicely done sir thank you jeff
you're up next are you ready
yes sir
[Music]
well jeff looks like the other laundry
did break off
do you know what this is still very
sturdy
but let's see how much damage is done
internally
he's got some broken ribs right here
broken bones throughout it went all the
way through
and even through armor you pierce the
skin and you cause some internal damage
jeff your weapon will kill awesome
good job thank you gentlemen this is the
strength test
the warhammer was a favorite on the
medieval battlefield so i'm going to
take your warhammer and to test its
strength and durability i'm going to
take several blows
against our stone wall and see how much
of this i can move
craig you're up all right let's do it
[Music]
wow that that held up really well and
that's pretty much a hole i could crawl
through
that'll work perfect so the handle
what i do like is i could swing it
one-handed but with two hands
i could generate a heck of a lot of
energy beautiful job
excellent excellent thank you jeff
you're up let's knock it down
[Music]
it's long and when i was swinging it was
way out in front of me as opposed to
being close and in control
shot some sparks off right seen that
all in all a good performance great
[Music]
craig jeff you were given five days at
your home
forge to fabricate war hammers and they
both performed very well
in our weapons tests but there can only
be one forged empire champion
[Music]
craig you are the forged and fire
champion congratulations
thank you jeff your weapon did not make
the cut
please surrender your warhammer
i respected the judge's decision if i
knew what i knew now
i would have changed some things
craig congratulations you were the
forest and fire champion
it was a fun challenge craig you will
also be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars i'm just stoked
it's crazy this experience it was a
grueling process you know i got to do
something that i really enjoyed and i'm
really passionate about i came here for
my son
i mean it doesn't get any better than
that
you